bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir c'est
vous Jean-Christophe bonsoir ministre
des Solidarités de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées beaucoup de vos
dossiers font l'actualité celui des
EHPAD dont les résidences s'apprêtent à
affronter une nouvelle canicule la
proposition de loi sur le Bien Vieillir
le grand âge qui avait fait grand bruit
à l'Assemblée elle revient on en parlera
et puis bien sûr le service public de la
petite enfance que vous promettez après
le rapport choc de l'IGAS sur les
crèches que vous aviez commandées on va
en parler de tout cela dans la deuxième
partie mais on commence ce soir avec
l'état d'urgence psychiatrique l'attaque
au couteau d'Annecy et le fait divers
sordide de Bordeaux ont jeté une lumière
crue sur l'enjeu de la santé mentale
dans notre pays c'est un continent qui
reste à conquérir à lâcher hier en
conseil des ministres Emmanuel Macron
alors la psychiatrie s'effondre et on
regarde ailleurs alors qu'est-ce qu'on
fait grand débat dans un instant avec
mes invités sur ce plateau avant de
retrouver nos affranchis pour leur
partie prix et puis Bourbon Express bien
sûr l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée
voilà pour le programme vous êtes prêts
ça vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
cela fait des années que les psychiatres
alertent dans le désert l'agression à
Bordeaux d'une grand-mère et de sa
petite fille par un homme qui souffrait
de troubles majeurs du comportement
sera-t-elle l'occasion d'une véritable
prise de conscience et surtout
l'occasion de passer aux actes la
psychiatrie par en pauvre de la santé
publique on en parle avec vous ce soir
Sandrine Josso bonsoir et merci d'être
là vous êtes députés à modem de
Loire-Atlantique vous êtes membre de la
commission des affaires sociales à
l'Assemblée et du Comité d'études sur la
santé mentale j'ai appris son existence
aujourd'hui vous me direz ce que vous
faites exactement dans ce comité
d'études vous débattez ce soir avec
Elise le boucher bonsoir merci d'être là
vous êtes député la France insoumise de
la Sarthe et éducatrice spécialisée en
pédopsychiatrie de professions bonsoir
Mathieu Belhassen bienvenue vous êtes
psychiatre ancien chef de service à
l'hôpital d'Asnières aujourd'hui vous
travaillez au baptu le Bureau d'aide
psychologique universitaire dans les
Hauts-de-Seine et vous êtes auteur de la
révolte de la psychiatrie les ripostes à
la catast gestionnaire s'est aux
éditions La Découverte enfin bonsoir
pierre Lévis sous sang ravi de vous
accueillir vous êtes aussi
pédopsychiatre on va parler des troubles
psychiques des jeunes après le covid
manifestement ils explosent il y a un
rapport du Haut Conseil à la famille à
l'enfance sur la flambée des
psychotropes qui a fait grand bruit chez
les jeunes on en parlera vous êtes aussi
experts psychiatrique bien connu nommée
auprès des tribunaux monsieur le
ministre vous êtes aussi ancien patron
de la Croix-Rouge forcément ce sujet là
voilà vous avez été confronté à cette
question de la santé mentale n'hésitez
pas à intervenir quand vous le souhaitez
on commence par planter le décor avec la
mi Stéphane blackovski le chrono de
Blacko c'est parti
et je me retourne comme chaque soir pour
vous accueillir mon cher Stéphane
bonsoir je vous invite à faire de même
Jean-Christophe alors ce dossier
difficile alors vous savez que si les
faits divers prennent autant de place
dans les médias c'est pas seulement pour
faire monter l'audience en jouant sur
nos peurs notre fascination pour le pire
alors bien sûr que c'est ça évidemment
mais c'est aussi parce que les faits
divers permettent parfois d'attirer
l'attention sur un problème plus profond
de notre société donc cette semaine on a
tous été choqué par l'agression de cette
grand-mère et sa petite fille à Bordeaux
et on a vu que la graisseur était restée
très peu de temps garde à vue il a été
placé en hôpital psychiatrique mais le
fait n'est pas vraiment isolé d'autres
fois et ont marqué le dernier mois et
qu'un jour c'était ce terrible drame à
une fille on s'est beaucoup interrogé
sur l'agresseur aujourd'hui il est ton
hôpital psychiatrique et il y a un mois
autre fait qui a choqué l'opinion en
France c'était à Reims une infirmière
qui a été assassinée par quelqu'un qui
se trouve peut-être de gros troubles
psychiatriques et donc le président la
sortie du Conseil des ministres au
Conseil des ministres a fait ce
commentaire qui était dans le Parisien
en disant que derrière la violence qui
monte dans la société il y a un enjeu de
santé mentale et en parlant donc de la
psychiatrie il disait c'est un continent
qui reste à conquérir un continent
conquérir on reconnaît le Président il
est toujours ce vocabulaire guerrier
quand il veut montrer sa détermination
sauf que quand on regarde la presse
régionale ben c'est pas vraiment une
conquête plutôt une déroute regardez le
nombre de lits qui ont fermé et c'est
uniquement depuis le début de l'année un
peu partout en France donc l'explication
on la voit ça se résume assez bien à
Caen on ferme des lits parce qu'on
manque de médecins et donc on ne peut
plus accueillir les patients donc les
conséquences elles s'affiche elle aussi
dans la presse régionale c'est à dire
que Angoulême par exemple dans la
Charente Libre on dit bah il y a de plus
en plus de cassychiatriques qui sont
dans la rue on n'arrive pas à les
accueillir des gens qui peuvent se
mettre à crier et mettre nu mais encore
plus grave c'était l'an dernier les
psychiatres disaient bah on manque
tellement de personnes que ce qui va
arriver ce qui arrive déjà c'est qu'on
peut pas surveiller des patients donc on
peut être amené à les enfermer ou
alors que faire je vous rassure la
solution est très simple il suffit
d'investir plus de moyens pour embaucher
plus de médecins il y a quand même un
petit problème c'est que la psychiatrie
n'est pas le seul secteur qui a besoin
de plus de moyens on écoute le ministre
François Brown notre psychiatrique comme
les urgences comme les maternités comme
notre système de santé cela fait des
mois des années qu'il est en difficulté
nous le savons il a un petit peu déprimé
aussi c'est pas facile un ministre de la
santé comme boulot mais il y a quand
même des gestes qui ont été faits il y a
eu d'abord des Assises de la psychiatrie
c'était en 2021 que le président avait
voulu il y a des mesures qui ont été
lancées depuis donc ce numéro 314 de
prévention du suicide je crois qu'il y a
environ 9000 4 suicides par an en France
c'était il y a deux ans l'an dernier
c'était mon parcours psy donc qui permet
d'avoir des consultations psy 8 dans
l'année bon alors les professionnels
sont pas très contents ils ont
l'impression que ça marche pas très bien
mais en tout cas il faut pas se faire
d'illusion c'est une si on veut vraiment
conquérir ou reconquérir IR la
psychiatrie ça va prendre du temps et
c'est ce que dit Arnaud Robinet donc qui
est maire de Reims évidemment qui est
Renaissance qui est psychiatre et qui
est aussi président de la Fédération des
hôpitaux publics en l'écoute il faut
dire la vérité aux Français former des
infirmières quelques années former des
médecins c'est 10 ans donc on va vivre
des moments tendus en termes de
psychiatrie et puis on l'a vu la covid a
fortement impacté l'état de santé
mentale d'un grand nombre de nos
concitoyens notamment chez les jeunes
ah oui en plus il y a les jeunes ce que
j'avais prévu de finir sur notre
optimiste mais il y a une étude qui
vient de sortir aujourd'hui qui dit que
depuis le confinement et du covid le
nombre d'enfants qui ont des troubles
psychiatriques et en augmentation et
donc vous voyez la presse en parlait ce
matin donc évidemment non seulement la
psychiatrie est en crise mais l'avenir
ça difficile donc je sais bien que plus
on est tout mignon des bas mais comme il
y a pas assez de chaise je vous laisse
je vais engueuler dans les couloirs
merci merci beaucoup Stéphane je vais
commencer avec vous Mathieu bellassel
dans l'introduction de votre de votre
livre vous avez mis quelques citations
quelques témoignages glaçons en exergue
face à l'indifférence ici on crève
hôpital psychiatrique du Rouvray près de
Rouen on ne veut pas plus de salaire
plus de congés on veut des moyens
humains hôpital psychiatrique d'Amiens
bienvenue dans l'hôpital psychiatrique
de la honte centre hospitalier du Havre
comment on en est arrivé là en fait on
est arrivé là par 30 ans d'un
public dans une destitution de ce que
c'est que vraiment les soins on en est
arrivé là en fait ce que vous citez là
c'est 2018-2019 c'est les premières
greffes pour la dignité de l'accueil des
premiers concernés des psychiatriser ça
vient juste après le soulèvement des
EHPAD juste avant les soulèvements des
urgences le collectif intergence etc et
en fait vous avez dit là tout à l'heure
dans la petite introduction il y avait
les assises de la psychiatrie c'est pas
vrai c'était les assises de la santé
mentale alors les mots sont très
importants parce que depuis 2005 2010 en
fait on s'intéresse plus à la
psychiatrie on s'intéresse à la santé
mentale et la santé mentale c'est au
fond c'est devenu un opérateur
économique c'est-à-dire avoir une
population en bonne santé mentale
permettra de remplir les objectifs
stratégiques de l'Union européenne ça
c'est le livre vert de l'Union
européenne c'est en 2005 et en fait ça a
eu des traductions très concrètes dans
les hôpitaux qui est que on a réorienté
les soins le temps qu'il faut pour les
patients c'est à dire des fois le temps
long vers du diagnostic de l'orientation
les gens de l'évaluation et en fait
finalement les gens ne sont plus soignés
ils sont certes plateformés parce qu'il
y a des pleins de plateformes
diagnostiques qui se développent les
assises de la santé mentale étaient un
je dirais un cirque pour pas être
complètement méprisant c'est à dire que
on a pas parlé des sujets qui fâchent on
n'a pas parlé du fait que l'isolement et
la contention augmente de manière
massive c'est à dire que quand la
personne qui fait le crime à Reims dit
j'ai la haine des blouses blanches il y
a des fois
il y a de quoi avoir la haine des
blouses blanches parce que la
maltraitance institutionnelle se
développe et si vous voulez c'est fait
divers qui sont tragiques pour tout le
monde ils montrent un système en
déshérence et ce système en fait c'est
pas avec des mesures raides comme les
assises la santé mentale la télé
psychiatrie et toutes ces historiques
mais de quoi pour vous l'hôpital on va
commencer par c'est compliqué la
psychiatrie que il y a l'hôpital
psychiatrique il y a des consultations
psychiatriques dans un hôpital classique
et puis il y a évidemment toutes les
centres de l'accueil structure en amont
jusqu'à un cabinet privé délicat de la
liste ou psychiatre sur l'hôpital
psychiatrique de quoi il souffre le plus
succinctement la première chose c'est le
climat sécurité qui existe depuis des
années à créer du sécuritaire dans les
mentalités des professionnels et tout le
monde ça c'est la première chose la
deuxième chose c'est les gens ne sont
plus formés la troisième chose c'est que
les gens partent de l'hôpital
psychiatrique les soignants toutes
catégories professionnelles confondus là
vous avez parlé des psychiatres mais les
infirmiers les aides soignants etc
pourquoi parce qu'il n'y a plus de sens
au travail le sens au travail c'est pas
d'enfermer d'attacher les gens c'est de
les accompagner le temps qu'il faut ça
on peut plus le faire parce qu'avec les
critères de rentabilité et la
destruction massive du service public
partout et bah on a pu les moyens de le
faire
les grèves elles étaient pas sur la
rémunération elles étaient vraiment sur
la dignité de l'accueil des patients la
France manque de lipsychiatrique 65% de
moins qu'en Allemagne pourquoi nous ça
nous arrive ça c'est la même chose sur
le nombre de psychiatre il a
considérablement baissé
-40% en 40 ans pourquoi on a
l'impression que on est face à un
système en totale des errance
moi ce que j'aimerais c'est qu'on
recontextualise il y a bien sûr la
psychiatrie et l'état de santé mentale
donc il y a un Français sur 4 qui
déclare avoir des troubles anxieux des
troubles dépressifs donc là il faut
vraiment faire le distinguer entre les
deux parce que là j'ai l'impression le
mélange la très grande majorité des gens
qui souffrent de troubles psychiques ne
sont pas hospitalisés ça il faut bien le
répéter évidemment mais là je voudrais
qu'on parle de l'hôpital psychiatrique
le manque de lit comment vous vous
l'expliquez c'est pas c'est pas possible
on a l'impression d'un tabou la crise de
l'hôpital est là mais alors la crise
dans la crise psychiatrique à l'hôpital
personne n'en parle justement pour
revenir sur ce que disait monsieur
effectivement la santé mentale de toute
façon est un tabou et donc à l'intérieur
de tout ça c'est vrai que il est
important aujourd'hui d'arrêter de
détourner le regard là dessus nous on a
fait actuellement quelque chose je pense
de très bien à l'Assemblée nationale on
a commencé à mettre un pied dans la
porte avec une oie sur l'accompagnement
psychologique des couples confrontés à
la fausse couche avec aussi le parcours
psy qui est devenu le soutien pour venir
aux solutions
d'entendre l'état des lieux les mots
qu'on place sur un état des lieux pour
comprendre et prendre la mesure de
l'alerte pierre Lévis ou sans votre
regard déjà sur l'hôpital psychiatrique
aujourd'hui alors dans le dans le champ
de la pédopsychiatrie il y a une
fermeture de 60% de lits de
pédopsychiatrie donc on ne peut plus
répondre déjà aux besoins sévères par
rapport aux urgences 60% 60% et si l'on
voit comment sont remplies ces lignes
ils sont remplis après de 55% par des
enfants maltraités récupérer par la zone
donc alors que normalement population
Azo c'est 2%. donc ça veut dire qu'on ne
sait absolument pas quoi faire derrière
le parce que pour nous le continent noir
des continents noirs c'est le chant de
la maltraitance et le parent pauvre de
la psychiatrie c'est la pédopsychiatrie
c'est-à-dire on est le parent pauvre du
parent pauvre c'est à dire qu'il y a une
diminution drastique de de tous les de
tous les points qu'on a pu citer
précédemment donc oui le champ de la
maltraitance est totalement sous-estimé
dans les pays occidentaux on évalue à
10% de la population de des enfants
c'est-à-dire ceux qui ferait
1,4 millions d'enfants maltraités faut
savoir qu'on en prend en charge 300 000
à l'ASEE et social à l'enfance donc vous
voyez à quel point on est dans un dans
un champ mais désertifié et par rapport
à l'attractivité de la pédopsychiatrie
alors déjà la psychiatrie n'est
absolument pas une spécialité pourvue
pour plein de raisons peut-être
expliquer mais alors la pédopsychiatrie
encore moins c'est à dire c'est
absolument pas un champ qui est qui est
qui est attractif le champ est encore
moins le champ social de la maltraitance
donc on est vraiment dans un état par
rapport à l'âge d'or que j'ai enfin
l'âge d'or les années 70
parce que en fait très très vite ça n'a
plus été un âge d'or parce que le
numerus clausus est très très
vitalus ça a été dans les années 70 donc
très très vite il y avait un moment dans
la dans toute la région Paris
Île-de-France il va y avoir quelque
chose comme ça sans psychiatre et puis
ma promotion on était 70 ça veut dire
que très concrètement en hôpital
psychiatrique aujourd'hui il y a des
patients non pris en charge ça c'est
c'est une évidence il y a des gens qui
souffrent de troubles psychiatriques qui
devraient être hospitalisée qui sont
souvent il faut le dire dans la rue
parce qu'il y a voilà des des
superpositions de difficultés notamment
de la détresse de la misère sociale
c'est ça aujourd'hui le la réalité du
pays bien sûr que que c'est ça
évidemment je voudrais rebondir
justement sur l'état de la psychiatrie
aujourd'hui
je suis assez Farid dans ton est proposé
du ministre de la santé du président de
la République qui harmonisation dit
lui-même ça fait des années nous le
savons et un président qui dit on a un
continent à conquérir c'est ça ça fait
il a posé la question le problème de la
santé mentale on a une liste de faits
divers dramatique ces dernières semaines
mais pour monter à des années il y a
toujours eu des alertes et c'est vrai
que on a souvent ce débat alors je
remercie ce débat ce soir mais ce débat
suite à des faits divers on n'a pas de
réflexion en prenant de la hauteur je
trouvais que c'est une forme de prise un
peu déformant de rentrer dans ce débat
parce qu'il y a aussi une question
sécuritaire que de dire au fond
ces personnes là sont dangereuses parce
qu'elles sont
comment dire psychiatriquement atteinte
certains diront ce sont des fous alors
que la réalité c'est pas ça elles sont
plus vulnérables statistiquement ces
personnes que que dangereuses le prisme
les défaussé parce que du coup on réagit
par l'émotion on est tous forcément
heurtés par les images qu'on voit par
les agressions mais dans les chiffres je
pense que c'est le docteur pourront
confirmer les personnes souffrant de
troubles psychiatriques qui sont pas les
plus violents dans la société et elles
sont même souvent elles-mêmes victimes
plus vulnérables puisqu'elles sont comme
vous l'avez dit dans la détresse dans la
rue dans la précarité donc elles sont
plutôt elles en première ligne aussi de
ces violences mais ce qui se passe mon
psychiatrie c'est surtout symptomatique
de la crise sociale qu'on vit
aujourd'hui de la crise de notre système
de santé bien sûr mais aussi des
services publics de la justice de
l'école donc c'est vraiment un réflexion
globale qu'il faut avoir et c'est vrai
qu'on entend peu cette idée qu'en fait
si on arrive à avoir des statistiques
c'est pas simple les statistiques en
matière de psychiatrie ces personnes là
sont souvent plus vulnérables peu
dangereuses d'Anne Lovel qui date de
2002 il me semble qui montrait que les
personnes en souffrance psychique sont
sept fois plus victim que la population
générale
si vous voulez en effet l'effet divers
montrent une portion très congrue
d'ailleurs les les passages à l'acte
criminels sont beaucoup moins dans la
population qui a des troupes psychiques
que dans la population entre guillemets
normales aussi remettre ça en
perspective qui avait travaillé en HP
comme on dit
ça vous est arrivé de renvoyer quelqu'un
alors que vous avez le sentiment que il
y a eu des passages à l'acte possible et
qu'il fallait plutôt qu'il soit
hospitalisé le problème c'est que c'est
une question d'arbitrage dont on n'est
pas responsable c'est-à-dire que la
pénurie organisée on en est pas
responsable je vous explique par exemple
quand vous avez une trentaine de lits
d'hospitalisation sur une unité de
secteur que vous avez cinq personnes qui
sont aux urgences qui va falloir les
hospitaliser donc dans votre secteur
qu'est-ce que vous faites il va falloir
que vous fassiez cinq sorties pour parce
que sinon les gens restent aux urgences
vont pas bien s'agit encore plus donc se
font attacher etc donc vous devez faire
un arbitrage impossible alors quand le
positif ambulatoire et suffisamment
étoffé vous pouvez voir les gens assez
vite et puis qui a un climat de
confiance qui s'est instauré vous pouvez
les faire sortir plus tôt mais oui il
est arrivé il arrive et il arrive tout
le temps en ce moment d'avoir ce
syndrome de la porte tournante on se dit
bah très bien la personne on l'a fait
sortir et puis bah elle reviendra de
nouveau contrainte etc le problème c'est
que les victimes de ça c'est les
patients et leur famille
les professionnels sont des victimes
secondaires c'est à dire que on fait mal
notre travail et on veut pas faire mal
notre travail mais ceux qui morfle
vraiment ce sont les patients et pour
répondre aussi à
cette question de la dérive sécuritaire
là les faits divers il y a eu 2003 il y
a eu 2008 à chaque fois c'était des lois
qui renforçaient la criminalisation des
malades mentaux il y a eu en 2018 la
circulaire colon qui disait on va tous
les patients qui sont hospitalisés sans
leur consentement on va croiser les
fichiers avec les fichiers s les
terroristes donc il y a ça dans
l'imaginaire politique en ce moment
et quand vous recevez des patients ben
forcément que vous soyez soignant où
vous soyez un citoyen normal et ben vous
flippez un peu vous voyez et c'est ça
qui explique aussi le fait qu'on est
moins dans l'accueil et moins dans
l'hospitalité et ça produit des dents on
va essayer de parler des solutions dans
un instant à ce stade du débat
Jean-Christophe combe déjà l'ancien
patron de la Croix-Rouge vous vous avez
été confronté les maraudes de la
Croix-Rouge dans les rues des grandes
villes c'est des appels au 115 et
parfois les structures d'accueil
d'hébergement d'urgence sont saturés
l'accompagnement psychiatrique ne répond
pas quelle est votre témoignage c'est un
sujet qui est extrêmement complexe que
je trouve intéressant dans le dans le
débat c'est aussi ce que ça signifie
aussi du regard du regard qu'on peut
porter sur la vulnérabilité les
personnes effectivement qui sont à la
rue qui sont souvent effectivement
atteintes de troubles psychologiques
elles sont particulièrement vulnérables
et lorsqu'on est dirigeant d'une
association humanitaire notre premier
rôle c'est de les protéger c'est de les
accompagner c'est de les aider il y a
quelque chose de très frustrant
effectivement dans notre système c'est
que c'est très compliqué de sortir
quelqu'un de la rue quand bien même on
aurait tous les moyens de disposition
pour le faire suffisamment de soignants
de professionnels de santé etc c'est
quelque chose qui est très compliqué et
qui est très frustrant et moi mon rôle
lorsque j'étais directeur de la
Croix-Rouge quand c'était de les
protéger et de les aider à vivre dans
des conditions qui étaient
particulièrement difficiles la deuxième
réflexion que je porte parce qu'elle
concerne aussi directement le secteur
dont j'ai la responsabilité aujourd'hui
social médico-social c'est la question
de la pénurie de professionnels et là on
a un vrai sujet c'est à dire que quand
bien même aujourd'hui on alerte sur
cette on a un constat partagé presque
transpartisan sur l'urgence en fait de
la situation il n'y a pas de parole
magique parce que la réalité c'est que
on n'a pas les professionnels et on les
aura pas non plus demain quand bien même
on investira massivement sur le secteur
il va falloir des années pour reformer
des professionnels dans ces dans ces
services et pas seulement des médecins
tous les professionnels soignants des
infirmières des aides-soignantes enfin
il faut du courage et aussi de
l'humilité parce que ça va prendre du
temps vous êtes d'accord avec ça pierre
Lili Soussans oui mais alors c'est pas
avec des politiques avec mon parcours de
soins qu'on va arriver à tirer des
psychologues pour soigner les gens c'est
même limite insultant pour les
psychologues qui s'occupent justement
des patients 30 euros 8 consultations
gratuites c'est c'est vraiment pas du
tout ce qu'on attend justement
on a parlé de l'hôpital psychiatrique
mais il y a aussi l'amant les fameux
CMPP rappelez-moi centre
médico-psychopédagogique et puis il y a
aussi surtout le médical c'est à dire
aujourd'hui j'ai vu j'ai vu passer pas
mal de papiers
sont menacés c'est-à-dire le champ
médical et menacé ce sont des structures
qui accueillent avant justement dans la
pré guerre assuré un maillage de toute
la France aussi bien dans le champ
adulte que dans le champ
pédopsychiatrique et tout ce maillage a
été attaqué depuis 20 ans donc on
enferme des aujourd'hui
l'exemple de la covid était une bonne
idée c'est-à-dire il y avait déjà le
maillage pour répondre à toutes les
urgences pédopsychiatriques on a
absolument pas utilisé le maillage des
CMP alors qu'il était déjà là et que bah
interrogé les pouvoirs publics pourquoi
alors que alors que ce maillage fait
dans l'après-guerre par toute la
psychiatrie humanitaire pose guerre n'a
absolument pas été utilisé pendant la
covid alors que nous étions tous là pour
accueillir toutes les urgences et les
dégâts de la covid aussi bien chez les
adolescents que chez les enfants mais
aussi chez les maires c'est-à-dire on a
tous les dégâts de toutes les
interactions mère bébé pendant cette
période qui ont eu des effets désastreux
exemple quelle forme de symptômes ça
prend c'est à dire lorsque vous avez une
lorsque vous mettez une mer avec un bébé
dans les dans les premiers jours dans
les premières semaines dans un espace
complètement fermé bah voilà ça ça rend
enfin je veux pas dire que ça rend fou
mais ça rend extrêmement
plus difficile
aux interactions avec le bébé avec des
effets extrêmement délétères dans les
premières semaines et dans les premiers
mois alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait on y
vient aux solutions mais d'abord je
voudrais quand même qu'on se rende dans
un hôpital psychiatrique c'est pas un
hôpital psychiatrique c'est un hôpital
classique mais il y a une consultation
psychiatrique c'est l'hôpital
d'Aubervilliers en Seine-Saint-Denis
avec l'AFP pierre Michael Carniel vous
présente son reportage
dans cet hôpital psychiatrique
d'Aubervilliers on soigne la dépression
les troubles anxieux alimentaires la
bipolarité ou bien l'autisme et la
schizophrénie le spectre est large ces
images ont été tournées en 2020 pourtant
aujourd'hui rien n'a changé le personnel
en sous-effectif est obligé de s'adapter
sur 80 patients certains doivent être
isolés donc chaque secteur a une ou deux
chambres de ce type là qui sont occupés
par des patients qui vont être agités ou
qui ont fait un passage à l'acte
agressif qui sont en tension liées à
l'angoisse ou à plein d'autres choses
mais en tout cas qui pourraient être
contenu par une présence infirmière à
leurs côtés et le manque des effectifs
dans les équipes conduisent à utiliser
de façon plus fréquente cette chambre là
pour isoler temporairement le patient et
ce qui pour nous une dégradation de
l'offre de soins une situation déjà
difficile empirée par la crise covid
budget réduit crise d'évocation
aujourd'hui 30% des psychiatrie reste
vacants laissant des services
sinistrés-soignants pour 24 patients
donc quand un patient a besoin d'un peu
plus de temps pour dire comment comment
il va ou comment il ne va pas ce qui ne
va pas dans sa tête s'il a des
hallucinations s'il est délirants si
voilà le fait de prendre le médicament
ça lui donne des effets indésirables ou
quelque chose comme ça ça peut être
vraiment très minime à quelque chose de
très grave on n'a pas ce temps ce temps
qui nous est limité parce qu'on nous
demande de plus en plus d'être dans
l'administratif dans le logistique dans
certains territoires comme ici en scène
Saint-Denis les patients sont plus
vulnérables ce qui complique encore plus
la prise en charge on a les indices de
précarité les plus importants donc
précarité génère plus facilement des
troubles mentaux de la même façon que
les populations migrantes ont plus
facilement des difficultés
psychologiques liées à leur parcours
traumatique et voilà donc on a nos
difficultés liées aux services publics
psychiatriques et avec ces populations
plus en difficulté que partout
d'ailleurs des troubles qui touchent de
plus en plus de Français y compris les
jeunes ce centre leur a même dédié une
unité un adolescent sur deux de 11 à 15
ans souffre de troubles d'anxiété ou de
dépression un stress qui se traduit par
défaut biscolaires des addictions aux
écrans et de plus en plus de tendances
suicidaires
en France on compte 24 suicide par jour
évidemment la palette des troubles
psychiques elle est elle est très grande
il faut bien distinguer les pathologies
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce que
vous attendez je vais demander aux
praticiens puis ensuite aux politiques
bien les vis sous sang déjà le rapport
de la le rapport du Haut Conseil de la
famille et de l'enfant a fait un rapport
saisissant on a un effet ciseaux entre
l'augmentation de 60 à 110% de
prescription de psychotropes pour les
enfants et parallèlement à ça une
diminution par quatre de consultations
dans les CMP c'est à dire que c'était
très frappé par ce rapport que vous
citez qui fait la Une d'ailleurs de
l'offre aujourd'hui de moins en moins
fait et le médicamenteux de plus en plus
fait et là faut je le croise avec ce
qu'a dit mon collègue tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire avec ce qu'on appelle la
gouvernance par les nombres c'est à dire
le fait que on ne soigne plus les
patients mais on soigne des nombres et
on soigne des indices et ça ça a été
dévastateur dans le démaillage
institutionnel des soins auprès des
patients on peut lire aussi parmi les
explications de cette flambée chez les
jeunes c'est tout simplement il y a plus
de prescription parce qu'il y a plus de
jeunes qui vont mal vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec ça c'est à dire que pour
nous c'est une d'abord il y a quelques
cas où oui il faut prescrire des
psychotropes mais surtout avant ça
faisait partie une fois de plus d'un
maillage d'un maillage de soins entre le
CMP le scolaire le et là tout a été
défait il y a de moins en moins de
psychologues scolaire il n'y a plus de
médecins scolaire il n'y a enfin le
la politique d'inclusion à l'école ça a
été un échec pourquoi ça a été un échec
bah parce que il y avait plus de
maillage possible donc du coup les
enfants en difficulté seront encore plus
en difficulté donc j'entends dans ce que
vous dites c'est qu'il faut revenir aux
acteurs territoriaux qui existaient ce
fameux maillage surtout ne pas supprimer
les fameux CMP ou CMPP et redonner un
peu confiance aux acteurs c'est ça
qu'est-ce que vous attendez
désirable la question des institutions
qui s'occupent du soin psychique or les
politiques je suis désolé mais vous avez
rendu indésir réellement moi je me
rappelle qu'après le premier confinement
il y avait des grèves devant les
hôpitaux on s'est fait gazer alors les
soignants étaient les héros d'un jour et
puis après on a été abandonné à notre
triste sort en fait il y aurait
énormément de gens qui voudraient
revenir dans le secteur public mais qui
n'y reviennent pas pourquoi parce qu'il
est devenu indésirable avec les normes
d'évaluation comptable qui sont
complètement à côté de la plaque avec le
fait que on ne peut plus soigner
vraiment les gens et faire notre cœur de
métier c'est ça le principal problème
moi je pense que il y a plusieurs choses
il y a un refaire que les formations des
professionnels soit des formations qui
soient intéressantes de redonner des
marges de manoeuvre aux professionnels
de faire que on entend de plus les
patients sur leurs soins parce que en
général on les considère comme des
objets de soins mais non les gens sont
des acteurs ils peuvent dire ce qu'ils
veulent et enfin moi je crois que il y a
une association de patients qui
s'appelle imapsea qui dit plus la
consultation est courte plus
l'ordonnance est longue et alors là
c'est un problème de société c'est quel
temps on va se donner pour soigner parce
que et la dernière chose c'est un petit
peu comme on attend des résultats
immédiats etc à une psychiatrie arrêtée
les lobbys alors il y a un lobby qui a
fait le passeport bipolaire les assises
de la santé mentale enfin le lobby
fondamental qui réorganise les soins
justement en ne faisant plus de soin
mais en faisant du diagnostic et
l'orientation il faut de nouveau faire
des soins et des dispositifs de soins et
arrêter avec juste les évaluations et
l'orientation alors on a deux
représentants ici de la majorité et du
gouvernement qui veut répondre allez-y
madame Josso alors donc ce que vous
dites c'est intéressant après j'ai quand
même l'impression qu'on n'habite pas
dans le même pays il y a des ce qu'on
appelle des projets territoriaux de
santé mentale ça c'est quand même porté
par des acteurs des territoires qui sont
capables de se mettre en réseau donc ça
c'est quand même très intéressant sur
des pratiques de bien traitance
travailler sur les compétences c'est pas
la base
psychosociales ça c'est vraiment à
développer je crois qu'il y a énormément
de choses qui sont faites peut-être pas
assez visible et ça c'est vrai c'est
aussi à nous tous de les rendre plus
visibles est-ce que on sent quand même
qu'il faut il faut un grand plan pour la
psychiatrie en France d'autres paysans
parce que c'est vrai que ce qu'on voit
là j'ai écouté François Braun ce matin
ses assises de la santé mentale mon
parcours psy les secouristes en santé
mentale déployés dans les entreprises ou
dans l'éducation nationale bientôt ça
vous semble adapté face aux praticiens
qui qui crient alerte quand même
il faut sans doute aller plus loin et je
laisserai le soir à François Brune de
faire ses annonces et
d'aborder des choses je sais pas c'est à
lui de le c'est à lui de le déterminer
et de le et de le dire mais je reviens
vraiment encore une fois sur la question
de la pénurie de de professionnels enfin
il y a pas de parole magique en la
matière et effectivement moi aussi j'ai
l'impression qu'on vit pas dans le même
pays il faut le dire il y a quand même
une réorganisation de l'hôpital il y a
un investissement massif sur les
professions en santé sur la formation
sur voilà suite aussi dur de présenter
etc enfin on a l'impression qu'on fait
rien
le psychiatre va devenir mais je vais
devenir fou
précisément à cause de ce qui était
intéressant tout à l'heure de toutes les
fermetures récentes de lits
aux gens que parce que on va dire il y a
un problème ça va se régler ça va ça va
ça va se régler
immédia elle date pas de ce gouvernement
là de toute façon vous l'avez tous si on
veut essayer d'être constructif et
depuis le covid ça se renforce
et il y a le fait que on ne fait plus de
soins réels c'est-à-dire que là vous
avez même vu dans les documentsaires là
qui sont passés on pense que le soin
c'est donner du médicament c'est pas
vrai le médicament c'est ce qui commence
c'est ce qui commence à faire du soin
mais le soin c'est la relation c'est de
fait de discuter avec les gens sur le
temps long etc c'est ça c'est ça qu'on
peut plus faire dans les hôpitaux et
dans les CMPP etc on a un an et demi de
fil d'attente en pédopsychiatrie les C
c'est plus d'un Andre c'est ça le pays
moi dans lequel je vis enfin faut
arrêter de penser que les professionnels
de terrain qui voient des patients tous
les jours sont déconnectés des réalités
stop ça c'est plus possible c'est plus
entendre c'est plus entendre si je puis
dire c'est une solution perdant c'est à
dire que tout ce que l'on ne fait pas
dans le champ de la prévention parce
qu'en fait le vrai champ pourquoi les
enfants vont mal c'est parce que les
parents vont mal d'accord il faut
remettre un peu les choses en
perspective et que donc tout le champ de
la maltraitance qui est une conséquence
effectivement de la violence des parents
c'est totalement sous-estimé et
absolument pas prise en charge c'est
toujours suite à des faits divers qu'on
est invité sur un plateau on essaye de
dire oh il y a un vrai problème de
maltraitance il y a une vraie
idéalisation du lien biologique qui fait
qu'on ne peut pas séparer les enfants de
parents maltraitants la loi taquet ça le
premier article c'est on va placer dans
la famille élargie
que l'on dit que la maltraitance c'est
quelque chose d'intergénérationnel donc
d'où on va placer dans la famille
élargie alors même que l'enfant il a
subi cette maltraitance là donc en fait
je suis d'accord avec mon collègue tout
est mal pris en charge le plateforme
psychiatrie ça débouché pour on va faire
de la stimulation cérébrale chez les
enfants mais comme si c'était ça ce
qu'on attendait c'est-à-dire nous le
chant est sinistré de la pédopsychiatrie
le traumatique envahit tout faut savoir
que 40 % des SDF entre 18 et 25 ans ont
un passé de maltraitance et je ne vous
dis pas les chiffres dans les prisons de
criminels
qui a été fait au niveau de l'inceste
donc oui cet effet au niveau de
l'inceste mais nous on attend la même
chose l'équivalent de la civisme mais au
niveau de la maltraitance physique qui
est une une civip si je puis dire c'est
à dire pour les violences physiques
vous êtes député vous pouvez aussi avoir
de l'initiative parlementaire qu'est-ce
que vous voudriez proposer si vous étiez
aux affaires qu'est-ce que j'étais aux
affaires c'est bien ça qui est difficile
c'est la question que je suppose dans la
majorité je suis posée
professionnelle du terrain parce que oui
il y a des choses qui sont mis en place
des conseils terribles de territoire
mais qui siège à ces conseils et c'est
ce sont les directeurs d'hôpital c'est
pas c'est pas des soignants qui sont qui
sont sur place donc entendons ce que ce
que réclame les soignants ils veulent
retrouver en effet du sens au travail
arrêtons de dévoyer le leur leur travail
mais je l'ai vu j'ai travaillé en CMP
j'ai vu l'évolution de ce qu'on demande
aussi aujourd'hui en CMU ondule des
plateformes de diagnostic et après on
oriente vers le libéral donc on est en
train on est en train de de continuer
d'accélérer la destruction de l'hôpital
public et donc de la psychiatrie c'est
quand même voilà c'est c'est on a posé
on a posé l'état d'alerte je pense que
voilà ce dossier là de toute façon il
existe il est à l'agenda on verra ce que
propose François Braun voulait rajouter
un tout petit mot à ce débat qui
s'achève oui c'est terminé de prendre le
sujet de la santé mentale du bien-être
mental
vraiment déjà là rien que ça il faut
prendre ça bien sûr tout de suite le
plus rapidement possible on est mais il
y a il y a des sauts j'avais bien
entendu aussi la distinction des mots
santé mental est une chose et un travail
parce que il y a
bien traitance il y a quand même des
solutions qui sont mises en place et ça
des solutions qui fonctionnent quand
vous avez par exemple un étudiant qui
est vraiment détresse qui n'a pas
d'argent qui va donc dans le parc
supprimer
du soutien il est il est quand même
heureux d'avoir des consultations qui
n'a pas à payer mon parcours si personne
vraiment mettre considère que c'est
forcément on est aussi capable de dire
que c'est ce qui fonctionne tout est
pesélectible de toute façon tout le
monde a bien compris que le problème ne
date pas d'hier donc voilà il est temps
de saisir c'est justement c'est ça merci
à vous merci pour vos témoignages merci
pour vos propositions c'est un dossier
qui nous tient à cœur ici LCP et on aura
à cœur de voir comment il trouve sa
suite vous restez avec moi
Jean-Christophe con une dizaine de
minutes les parties pris de nos
affranchis ce soir le regard d'Isabelle
Lasserre toute jaune vêtue sur le sommet
pour un nouveau pacte financier mondial
d'Emmanuel Macron une nouvelle histoire
d'école avec Yanis roder en colère ce
soir après l'arrêt des programmes
d'éducation médias faute de financement
et puis d'un Bourbon Express Stéphanie
Depierre de quoi nous parlez-vous ce
soir on parle de proposition de loi si
vous n'en faites pas ici à l'Assemblée
vous ratez votre vie de député ah et ben
j'ai hâte d'entendre ça et bien je vous
propose maintenant de parler un peu de
vos dossiers Jean-Christophe combe et
puis un peu de votre parcours vous allez
sur les bras les EHPAD après le scandale
hors pa les crèches après le rapport
choc de Liga ce que vous aviez commandé
en gros de la petite enfance à la fin de
vie ça fait beaucoup la vitesse est
signée ce soir par Maïté Frémont on en
parle ensemble juste après
si on vous invite Jean-Christophe combe
c'est pour nous parler d'un grand défi
de notre société prendre soin des plus
fragiles du plus jeune au plus agir de
la petite enfance au Seigneur vous êtes
derrière le Bien vieillir en France
mission essentielle quand on sait que
nous sommes les champions d'Europe du
nombre de centenaires 30 000 au compteur
quand on traite du grand âge on ne
s'adresse pas qu'aux personnes âgées on
parle aussi à leurs enfants à leurs
petits-enfants et plus largement à
toutes celles et ceux qui demain dans ce
secteur d'avenir trouveront des
opportunités sur le marché du travail à
41 ans Jean-Christophe combe on vous dit
issu de la société civile mais la
politique vous est tout de même
familière votre carrière vous la
commencez au groupe Union centriste au
Sénat c'était en 2003 puis en tant que
directeur de cabinet d'un député maire
aujourd'hui à la tête du ministère
dites-vous des vulnérabilités vous avez
en charge les dossiers des solidarités
de l'autonomie et des personnes
handicapées et ça tombe bien car
l'urgence sociale vous connaissez avant
d'intégrer le gouvernement
Jean-Christophe combe vous étiez
l'ancien directeur général de la Croix
Rouge Française une institution qui se
court chaque année près de 90 000
victimes
et sur votre bureau les dossiers
aujourd'hui s'amoncellent des crèches
visées pour maltraitance sur nos enfants
des EHPAD transformés en mouroir partout
un manque criant de personnel y compris
dans les maisons d'accueil pour
personnes handicapées face à toutes ces
situations une question ce soir
Jean-Christophe combe votre ministère
n'est-il pas celui d'un modèle social à
bout de souffle
réponse bonjour
on a un modèle social qui est qui est
riche qui est redistributif qui est
protecteur en revanche il faut qu'il
soit réformé il faut transformer et
si le président de la République est la
première ministre ont choisi de créer un
ministère des solidarités de l'autonomie
et des personnes handicapées un
ministère dédiées c'est la première fois
que ce ministère existe sur ce périmètre
là parce qu'il y a effectivement
beaucoup de travail et que ma feuille de
route est bien remplie de la petite
enfance on y va sur les dossiers dans
l'ordre on commence par la petite
enfance le manque de place en crèche
s'en connaît dans certaines villes il
est criant mais ce qui a pointé le
rapport de Liga ce que vous avez
commandé donc à beaucoup choqué
dysfonctionnements grave dans le
recrutement dans la formation des
personnels mais aussi dans l'accueil des
enfants avec des cas de maltraitance
dans certains établissements il y a même
des enquêtes qui ont été ouvertes
qu'est-ce qui va changer concrètement
d'abord rappeler que c'est un engagement
du Président de la République pendant la
campagne de créer 200000 places
d'accueil pour le jeune enfant
ici à 2030 c'est bon pour l'emploi parce
qu'il y a aujourd'hui 150 000 personnes
qui renoncent à un emploi pour pouvoir
accompagner leur enfant donc il y a un
sujet de conciliation entre vie
personnelle vie familiale et vie
professionnelle donc ça ça va être fait
et là tout de suite pour pour les gens
qui vont accoucher dans quelques mois
pour pouvoir et bien répondre aux
besoins des familles qui exprimaient
partout sur le territoire de
l'accessibilité d'une offre de trouver
une place de crèche une place d'accueil
chez une assistante maternelle partout
sur le territoire et accessible
financièrement
en 2027 ça sera 100000 places 100000
places nouvelle progression et ben ça on
va le travailler avec les collectivités
on va faire des du blog communal en fait
une autorité organisatrice donc vraiment
consacrée leurs compétences en matière
d'organisation de de l'offre et surtout
de recrutement
moi ce que j'ai dit et c'est pour ça que
quand je suis arrivé en juillet j'ai
choisi de saisir l'inspection générale
des affaires sociales pour amener une
jambe plus qualitative et comprendre en
fait ce qui se joue dans notre système
est-ce que il est performant est-ce que
c'est bon pour l'éducation des enfants
est-ce que je savais qu'il y avait des
problèmes puisque je suis arrivé par les
non parce que
largement choqués les Français pas
vraiment je pense qu'on les a objectivés
j'ai pas été étonné parce que j'étais
gestionnaire de crèches lorsque j'étais
à la Croix-Rouge aussi donc je sais
comment ça se passe je connais les
problématiques de pénurie de
professionnels voilà ce que je voudrais
dire aussi c'est que comme dans tout mon
champ de responsabilité il y a des
situations qui sont très hétérogènes il
y a des crèches où ça se passe très très
bien il y en a d'autres où ça se passe
pas bien il y a des situations qui se
d'ailleurs c'est ce que dit le rapport
qui a des situations qui sont très
hétérogènes
et les départements qui qui gèrent les
crèches faut recruter est-ce qu'il faut
augmenter les personnels les
rémunérations des personnels et donc que
l'État aide les collectivités davantage
notre activité des métiers c'est pas une
question de
toutes ces personnes sont souvent des
femmes qui disent que c'est difficile
que c'est pénible qu'il y a des horaires
fractionnés qui a des trajets en voiture
qui sont non prises en charge ici à
l'Assemblée vous savez que la nupaise
veut même créer un statut autonome pour
pour ces personnes là qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez et qu'est-ce que vous proposez
ce que je propose il y a un sujet
d'attractivité des métiers les sujets
organisationnels qui dépendent de chaque
de chaque métier bien un sujet de
conciliation entre vie personnelle et
vie professionnelle vous le disez par
exemple les auxiliaires de vie elles
souffrent de d'emploi du temps
fractionné de temps partiel subit de
problématiques aussi de prise en charge
de leur temps de mobilité etc donc dans
la proposition de loi sur le Bien
Vieillir on a déjà fait on a fait d'ores
et déjà un certain nombre de
propositions pour soutenir les
professionnels créer une carte
professionnelle ça a l'air de rien mais
c'est reconnaître en fait leur statut
dire que c'est un métier qui a des
compétences qui sont associés et qu'on
peut aussi imaginer des avantages on va
mieux financer les questions de mobilité
voilà permettre au conseil départemental
des fleuves de véhicules électriques
considérer le temps de travail le temps
de trajet le temps aussi d'analyse des
pratiques professionnelles des temps
aussi de concertation de confrontation
avec d'autres professionnels qu'on va
aussi rémunérer c'est des temps et ça
c'était une promesse du président de la
République l'augmentation des plans
d'aide avec des heures de convivialité
là aussi ça a l'air de rien
les arbitrages de Bercy il y a une
partie qui a été mis en loi de
financement à la sécurité sociale il y a
une partie qui seront dans la PPL bien
vieillir et puis il y a d'autres sujets
que j'inscrirai dans la feuille de route
bien vieillir que je présenterai dans
quelques jours et puis il y aura sans
doute d'autres discussions qu'on aura
bien vieillir dites nous un tout petit
peu parce que les Français sont encore
sous le choc du scandale horspea il y a
cette proposition de loi qui revient
c'est pas la même j'imagine vous allez
vous allez la demander on se souvient
que les critiques étaient vives d'un
grand qui n'était pas au rendez-vous de
de l'importance du sujet dépendant s'il
y avait même des critiques au sein de
votre majorité sur le Bien Vieillir
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire et bien
une grande réforme du grand âge et qui
tient pas seulement dans une loi il y a
des mesures qui sont naturels
législatives elles seront dans la
proposition de loi il y a des mesures
qui sont financières elles seront dans
le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité dans les projets de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale à
venir on a inscrit d'ailleurs dans la
PPL une loi de programmation qui va
permettre justement de programmer pour
les années à venir les moyens
nécessaires et l'argent qu'on souhaite y
investir et puis il y en aura plus
il faut se rendre compte que la branche
autonomie qui permet de financer en fait
l'accompagnement de la perte d'autonomie
dans le pays ou qui permet de financer
aussi des actions en faveur des
personnes en situation de handicap c'est
la branche la plus dynamique de la
sécurité sociale entre 2021 et 2026 elle
va prendre plus de 10 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires
et passer de 32 à 42 milliards d'euros
qui seront consacrés à cette branche
donc elle est très dynamique maintenant
faudrait que le Parlement
disent si il faut mettre plus d'argent
ou pas et donc ça on le discutera dans
le cadre de la loi de programmation mais
c'est déjà une progression extrêmement
dynamique qui va nous permettre de
renforcer le nombre de soignants dans
les EHPAD on a une trajectoire de plus
50 000 d'ici à 2027 c'est considérable
quand on sait les difficultés qu'on a à
recruter on va créer des places de
services de soins infirmiers à domicile
26000 aussi d'ici à 2027 va renforcer
les services d'aide à domicile tout ça
vous l'avez vous l'avez annoncé et on va
continuer il va falloir que derrière sur
les contrôles là encore dans les EHPAD
les choses ont changé parce que c'est ce
qui est aussi marqué les Français et là
on a une après un engagement juste après
horspea le gouvernement était très
réactif mais après décesseur la
commission des affaires sociales de
l'Assemblée nationale aussi avec la
présidente katabi qui ont été
particulièrement offensifs on a annoncé
qu'il y aurait que nos 7500 iPad
seraient contrôlés dans les deux ans
après la crise hors pa aujourd'hui on
met en oeuvre on a recruté 120
professionnels formés dans les agences
régionales de santé on a ciblé les EHPAD
qui étaient les plus à risque et ses
contrôles continuent et aujourd'hui on
suit aussi la mise en oeuvre de toutes
ces recommandations injonctions pour
améliorer la situation dans les EHPAD
mais là aussi il y a pas de parole
magique c'est ça prend du temps ça prend
du temps dire aussi que il y a tout un
tas d'endroits où ça se passe bien voilà
j'en visite beaucoup des EHPAD des EHPAD
public associatifs ou voilà on a reçu le
tableau ce qui est repart participe à
l'inattractivité des métiers on n'a pas
envie de s'engager dans des
établissements dont tout le monde pense
qu'ils sont maltraitants donc vous êtes
vous-même maltraitants
à LCP et puis pour cette feuille de
route vous l'annoncez quand le Bien
vieillir dans dans les dans les jours
qui viennent on regardera de très près
allez c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis leur parti pris pour nous
faire réagir ou les accueillent ensuite
bienvenue soyez voilà installez-vous
Isabelle Lasserre correspondant
diplomatique du Figaro ravi de vous
retrouver Yanis roder pour une nouvelle
histoire de d'école de la Fondation Jean
Jaurès notamment on commence comme
chaque soir par Bourbon Express histoire
du jour à l'Assemblée nous est racontée
ce soir par Stéphanie des pierres
bonsoir Stéphanie bonsoir et ce soir je
vous raconte une histoire d'inflation
Myriam pas celle des prix mais celle des
propositions de loi lundi ça ne vous a
probablement pas échappé François Ruffin
en lançait une pour le droit aux
vacances pour tous rien que pour cette
semaine et pour les insoumis c'est une
par jour et nous ne sommes que jeudi
mais c'est un sport partagé chez tous
les députés de l'Assemblée depuis juin
dernier il y a eu 767 propositions de
loi déposées le décompte on fait
beaucoup c'est beaucoup alors le
décompte n'est pas encore définitif il
le sera fin septembre on devrait
largement dépasser le chiffre de 2017 et
ce qui est remarquable Myriam c'est que
sur ces 767 propositions et bien
seulement 18 ont été adoptés
c'est-à-dire que 87% dans 97% je vois
vous avez raison d'entraide
n'aboutissent jamais et finissent à la
poubelle et je ne vous parle même pas
des propositions de loi claironner dans
les médias qui ne sont pas rédigés comme
celles par exemple de Louis Boyard sur
l'abonnement à Netflix et qui n'ont
toujours pas déposé bon alors à quoi ça
sert si elle est pas votée cette
proposition de loi Myriam c'est assez
simple à faire de la com et de la
politique surtout dans une assemblée
éclatée et sans majorité absolue c'est
le gouvernement je vous le rappelle qui
a la maîtrise de l'agenda législatif il
y a peu de place pour les initiatives
des députés et c'est encore pire si vous
êtes dans l'opposition alors déposez une
proposition de loi permet d'avoir un
article dans la presse un moment à la
télé de montrer à ses électeurs qu'on
travaille et même si infinie votre idée
n'a quasiment aucune chance d'être
discutée dans l'hémicycle écoutez
Antoine ver Morel il est député de la
Loire et lui il a écrit 12 propositions
de loi depuis son élection en juin il
était sur notre plateau il y a quelques
jours
c'est un acte politique fort j'en ai
fait une par exemple sur la suppression
des allocations aux parents maltraitants
qui m'a valu un rendez-vous avec la
secrétaire d'État en charge de l'enfance
qui m'a dit on étudie cette proposition
pour l'intégrer dans le projet de loi de
finance de la sécurité sociale à
l'automne et c'est aussi j'en ai déposé
une récemment sur la nationale 7 à Mably
qui est un sujet local qui m'intéresse
qui a un moyen de pression vis-à-vis du
gouvernement et pour moi la proposition
de loi et on le voit d'ailleurs dans nos
dans les niches et dans les elle est
vraiment d'abord et avant tout un outil
politique au service d'une cause
bien c'est clair Antoine Vermorel et ses
collègues républicains sont les
champions d'ailleurs à eux seuls ils ont
déposé presque un tiers des propositions
de loi de cette année alors qu'en fait
ils ne sont que 10% dans l'hémisme il y
en a quand même qui aboutissent
rassurez-moi oui on disait 18 tout à
l'heure alors ce sont surtout celles des
députés du camp présidentiel qui arrive
à être voté la loi anti-squad la loi
pour simplifier le permis de conduire ou
l'accès par exemple direct au kiné sans
passer par votre médecin traitant mais
il y a quand même cette année quelques
textes impulsés par l'opposition qui
arrive au bout du processus quand ils
sont soutenus par plusieurs groupes par
les politiques et par la majorité par
exemple la loi pour réguler l'univers
impitoyable des influenceurs ou celle
qui crée une aide d'urgence pour les
victimes de violences conjugales voilà
il y a quand même des sujets qui font
l'unanimité dans dans cette nouvelle
Assemblée l'inflation des PPL comme on
dit merci Stéphanie alors on parle de ce
sommaire avec vous Isabelle sommet sur
la finance organisé par le Président de
la République sur deux jours il prendra
la parole demain vous nous dites que
c'est pour rallier les pays du Sud
global comme on les appelle oui ça fait
partie de des efforts visant à rallier
le sud global parce que depuis la guerre
en Ukraine Myriam on s'est aperçu qu'il
existait un Sud global qui en fait a
refusé de choisir entre dans la guerre
entre la Russie et l'Ukraine alors le
sud global c'est un mot un peu barbare
qui est d'ailleurs contesté par beaucoup
mais qui sont caricature un petit peu se
veut l'héritier de du mouvement des Non
Alignés des années 70 un des pays comme
l'Inde à peu près émergents
émergents mais en plus en plus engagés
politiquement alors ces pays en fait on
fait exploser le mythe au début de la
guerre en Ukraine selon lequel dans les
grandes crises internationales l'Afrique
le l'Amérique du Sud et une partie de
l'Asie alignée forcément sa position sur
celle des pays occidentaux bah ça n'a
pas du tout été le cas au début de la
guerre on a vu que une quarantaine de
pays dont l'immense signe l'immense un
des pays beaucoup de pays africains en
fait on refusé de voter la résolution du
Conseil de sécurité qui condamnait la
guerre en Ukraine alors on s'aperçoit
que 16 mois après cette ambiguïté
persiste parce qu'on s'aperçoit que en
fait la guerre a révélé l'ampleur en
fait des changements à l'ordre sur la
scène internationale et qu'elle les a en
plus amplifié pourquoi me demander pour
quelle raison pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord parce que ces pays considèrent
que c'est une en gros ils disent c'est
une guerre de blanc une guerre entre
européen qui leur est complètement
étrangère ensuite il dénonce le deux
poids de mesure dont serait coupable le
les pays occidentaux qui accueillent les
réfugiés
Ukrainiens les bras ouverts alors que
ils essaient de repousser les autres les
réfugiés musulmans notamment et ils
aident énormément l'Ukraine en lui
fournissant des armes et aussi une aide
humanitaire et une aide une aide
financière plus généralement ces pays ce
qui sont très très divergent enfin qui
ont beaucoup beaucoup de de divergence
lutte contre la domination
occidentale du monde depuis 1945 ils
veulent changer le système d'où l'idée
d'Emmanuel Macron depuis plusieurs mois
d'essayer de les de les arrimer en fait
à sa position pour à court terme c'est
ça le premier objectif éviter qu'il ne
tombe complètement en fait dans le
panier russe alors avec quelle chance de
succès ce sommet pour ramener le chute
globale c'est pas le sur le sommet en
lui-même qui qui va décider mais pour
l'instant on n'a pas beaucoup de sucré
de succès par exemple on s'est aperçu
que Emmanuel Macron avait pas mal
investi avec l'Algérie mais le président
algérien teboun a annulé son voyage
plusieurs fois mais par contre il est
allé voir Vladimir Poutine et la crise
est consommée on s'aperçoit que tous les
tous les plans de paix en fait ou les
propositions de négociation de paix qui
ont été proposés par les pays du Sud ne
sont pas du tout des plans neutres et en
fait sont tous plus ou moins favorables
degré d'hiver avec la avec la position
de la Russie on s'aperçoit aussi que et
bien même 16 mois après le début de la
guerre le modèle Vladimir Poutine et
surtout le modèle de la Chine
c'est-à-dire un modèle autoritaire et
anti-occidental continue à séduire tous
ces pays or ces pays prennent de plus en
plus d'importance parce qu'avec le
retrait américain du Moyen-Orient et de
l'Europe a laissé la place à la Turquie
à l'Iran à la Chine qui consolide leur
opposition alors
il y a quand même un petit paradoxe
c'est que l'Occident est de plus en plus
critiqué et en même temps la guerre en
Ukraine a montré que il était resté uni
contre toute attente et complètement
soudée donc est-ce que peut-être que une
victoire en Ukraine pourrait peut-être
un jour lui enfin en tout cas c'est la
question qu'on peut poser lui rendre ses
ailes merci on verra ça on a encore un
petit peu de temps pour trancher on
verra merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'ailleurs on en parlera de ce sommet à
votre place demain jean-christ rendu
compte de la patronne de l'ONG one de
Bono de Youtube c'est Najat
Vallaud-Belkacem on reviendra sur les
fruits de ce sommet Yanis vous dit un
poussin un coup de gueule ce soir vous
voulez nous parler de l'éducation aux
médias et à la formation évidemment
c'est très important et on le voit à
l'heure des réseaux sociaux c'est un
rapport de la commission broner qu'il
avait préconisé les lumières à l'air
numérique remis au Président de la
République en effet Myriam les flux
ininterrompus des réseaux sociaux
rentrent aujourd'hui absolument
impératif d'éduquer notre jeunesse au
fonctionnement des médias et à la
construction de l'information en 2015
après l'attentat contre Charlie Hebdo
avec Laurence Bloch alors directrice de
France Inter et Emmanuel davier l'actuel
médiatrice de Radio France nous avions
créé interclasses exemple même de
projets innovants qui offre aux élèves
des quartiers populaires non seulement
la possibilité de s'initier au monde du
journaliste en réalisant tout au long de
l'année des reportages podcasts sur
France Inter avec des professionnels du
métier mais également de sortir de leur
univers quotidien par les lieux et par
les personnes qui le découvraient ou
rencontrer alors quels exemples des
exemples j'en ai des dizaines si je ne
parle que de mes élèves en 8 ans
d'interclasses ils ont pu rencontrer des
personnalités comme Bernard Cazeneuve
Claudia leur Adler des gens talentueux
dans leur domaine dans la haute couture
la cuisine le sport des philosophes des
sociologues des avocats et bien sûr bien
sûr des journalistes de France Inter qui
donnent de leur temps que je ne peux pas
citer quand ils sont nombreux mais il le
mériterait tous est-ce que ça marche
alors
cela fonctionnait Myriam car en réalité
il faut maintenant parler au passé la
direction de France Inter nous a informé
en début de semaine que faute de moyens
car l'éducation aux médias n'est plus
éligible au mécénat le projet
inter-classe s'arrêtait les élèves des
16 établissements situés dans des
espaces de relégation sociale et qui
avait l'immense chance de profiter de ce
formidable outil d'éducation à la
citoyenneté se voit privée d'une
exceptionnelle ouverture sur le monde
évidemment grosse déception pour vous
mais ça va au-delà oui je suis triste
pour les élèves mais je suis aussi amer
car en même temps que nous apprenions
qu'interclass s'arrêtait faute de moyens
financiers je suis tombé sur une petite
dépêche qui annonçait que France 2030 un
dispositif public qui vise à favoriser
les expérimentations et innovations
pédagogiques accordaient une subvention
parmi d'autres de 3 millions 200000
euros à une école dans le cadre d'un
appel à projet ah oui alors où est le
problème selon vous alors il faut bien
sûr financer la recherche Myriam mais là
on donne de l'argent public à une école
qui non seulement est une école privée
hors contrat mais qui plus demande entre
7 et 11000 euros par an pour isolariser
son enfant une école qui doit rendre
compte de sa rentabilité à des
actionnaires privés alors on aurait
torquera ce sont des lignes budgétaires
différentes c'est pour la recherche faut
pas tout mélanger d'accord bien sûr et
je sais que les rectorats
d'Île-de-France sont associés qu'il faut
espérer que cela profite à tous à long
terme mais on enlèvera pas Myriam ce
petit goût amer que j'ai dans la bouche
ni l'idée que regarde des 3 millions de
cent mille euros d'argent public donné à
cette école les 65000 euros nécessaires
à l'existence d'interclasses dédiée aux
élèves de nos quartiers ne sont pas
grand-chose voilà j'ose espérer que
votre parti pris passera pas inaperçue
sauver les interclasses ça vous parle
monsieur le ministre bien sûr je pense
qu'il faut vraiment que on investisse et
qu'on continue à investir
dans la jeunesse d'ailleurs hier on a
conclu avec la première ministre les
assises de la jeunesse rendez-vous de
2019 pour continuer les interclasses
voilà ça fait partie des choses qu'il
faut qu'on faut qu'on développe
évidemment et en particulier dans les
quartiers prioritaires de la ville voilà
moi en tant que ministre des solidarité
j'ai évidemment un attachement fort au
développement et à l'éducation de la
jeunesse j'aimerais aussi qu'on puisse
leur présenter d'autres types de de
métier qui ont beaucoup de sens des
infirmières des aides-soignants des
auxiliaires qui viennent à l'école de
cette émission on est en retard en tout
cas le message il est passé et il est
directement passé au gouvernement on
verra ce que ça donne ce petit ruban
vert que vous voyez place René à chez
mes invités ainsi que moi-même c'est
parce que c'est la Journée nationale du
don d'organe plus de 28
000 Français sont en attente d'une
greffe alors il suffit de dire oui pour
sauver des vies voilà pour cette
émission merci de votre fidélité tout de
suite votre soirée documentaire avec
Jean-Pierre grâce à demain
[Musique]